[Music]
Wow
stumbling in for two points wheel drives
and scores deal I off the glass pretty
play why Leonard at the other end
bo comes the other way and slams it in
[Applause]
it's not been one of his best games from
an offensive efficiency standpoint just
7 of 21 from the field strong move by
Bradley Beal to finish with the left
hand maybe looking at another great one
I don't song as grandma Vesta shoots it
teaches in the shooter for some point
Bradley Pele is going to knock him down
and he hits this shot to give him 30
points it is the 11th time this year the
Beal is one of them
[Applause]
Lenard in the paint contact score it
will go to the line Arisa gets being at
the point of attack but then no one's
there to help an easy bucket
[Music]
[Applause]
four straight possessions with a chance
to take the lead and Leonard gives his
team the advantage by three field
contact scores to tie the game at 131
close to five seconds Leonard gets it in
and they give him the ball spins into
paint and he scores
[Music]
[Applause]